41 gun salute is taking place
foreign
salutes are being fired across the
capital in honor of his birthday for the
first time this the king's troop Royals
artillery who are firing these volleys
and also the Band of Scots guards are
going to perform happy birthday after
these uh cannons off let's bring in are
all correspondent Laura bundock uh Laura
we've also heard about new role for the
King today marking his 74th birthday
following in the footsteps of his side
yeah that's right to coincide with his
birthday Buckingham Palace have
announced that the king will become the
new arranger of Windsor Great Park which
is opposed previously held by his father
Prince Philip the Duke of Edinburgh it
was a role that the Duke of Edinburgh
took seriously he was for example
responsible back in 1979 for
reintroducing Red Deer to the park so it
was interesting uh that it's been
announced the king will take over this
position the deputy Ranger at the park
has said that the prince's passion and
and his commitment to the natural world
will be invaluable as they try to become
a center of excellence he said for
environmental best practice so a big
role for the king and their photo has
been released to coincide with the
announcement a photo taken last week in
Windsor create part you can see the king
leaning and looking relaxed against an
ancient Oak Tree in the park there and
that role as I announced today on his
74th birthday you can see him there with
a walking stick and a Stripes tie we
understand as I say the photo taken last
week in Windsor that post has been held
interestingly for 460 years by The
Sovereign or a member of the sovereign's
family it is of course the big day for
the king not just his birthday but his
first birthday as Sovereign lots of
military occasions marking it one of
them as you see here in central London
the King Street Royal Horse artillery
firing a 41 round they'll an hour later
be 62 rounds fired from the Tower of
London by The Honorable artillery
company and we'll also have heard this
morning the band of the household
Cavalry also playing Happy Birthday
outside Buckingham Palace to coincide
with the Bucking Palace changing the
guard ceremony so several events taking
place on his birthday what one thing we
don't know interestingly is whether or
not he will have an official birthday as
well the Queen's birthday you may
remember was on the 21st of April but
she'd always have the official
celebration in June we haven't had
confirmation yet from the palace if that
will be the case for the king as well
often seeing that the summer events were
popular and it was traditionally in June
when the trooping the color ceremony was
held as well we don't know if that'll be
the case for the king but certainly as
we see here a military celebration of
the king's 74th birthday